welcome everybody to this webinar and i
am raghavindharan i'm a research
consultant and bioinformatics mentor
with prime biotic and i will be your
mentor throughout your research
fellowship program so i am very excited
to share with you how this program works
and we will answer
some specific questions related to what
is this program about and how to join
the program how to submit a project on
our mixed logics and
what are the general structure of the
program that will help you perform your
own bioinformatic research
with us so this program can be roughly
divided into three main straight stages
so at the first stage is a training
stage so this is a stage which sets the
direction for participants or students
like you to define in which area or
which research field that we are going
to work on so some of you might have a
very clear idea on which field or which
research topic that you want to work on
and some of you might have also had some
introduction to bioinformatics as a
course as a curriculum what is different
interaction means
so uh but some of you also would like to
gain more knowledge before making a good
decision so for those who are still
deciding and who doesn't who still are
not from a bioinformatics background
we always suggest you to start with very
two very basic courses that is
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and modules so these basic courses are
designed to introduce the basic concepts
of bioinformatics and this application
to different research fields or areas
that employs various omics types mixed
data types which can be subjected to
multitude of analysis methods so we are
introducing you
several methods so by the end of these
two introductory courses you should be
able to understand what are the
different methods employed for different
comics comics data types and also you
also should have a clear
idea of in which field or in which data
type or in what question that you want
to work on not question at least a focus
on which direction that you want to move
so at the end of the first stage you
should be able to for example
have all the necessary uh
skill sets to identify specific research
question that you would want to work on
so in this
stage where you are going to identify a
research topic so um
you will have to first find a data set
that has the potential to answer your
research question
so um
more on this little later so in the next
stages where you actively pursue you
pursue your research discussing whistles
impedances and
all the necessary suggestions and
feedbacks from mentors all along right
through
so after these three uh very important
phrases you will have to prepare a
presentation that you will submit in our
portal the omex logix portal as a
project so that you can showcase this
project and share with your network
appears and share
your poster if you have prepared in
conferences and in meetings scientific
meetings that you cannot
so let's again
go through okay for example um
sorry i think it's not stopping at one
point yeah so we uh over throughout the
course of this uh
throughout the course of these
this program we have a weekly progress
report form that you will have to fill
up and submit to us and you will have to
discuss your progress with the mentor at
least once in a week so these progress
reports are excellent
way
to evaluate how you progress through the
research fellowship program it is
helpful for you and also helpful for us
to find or to
place you where you are currently and
then to help you in at all the necessary
steps of
your research progress
so our learning resources for this
program includes
various courses that cover different
specialization fields so we have
specialization fields like that focuses
on the bioinformatics parts of the omics
field or a mixed data type that you
would want to start with like if you
want to work with metagenomics then you
can start with metagenomics courses if
you want to work with transcriptomics
you can start with transcriptomic course
that both of these courses and also
other ones goes in depth
in
in the type of data that you are going
to analyze and the various different
options of analysis methods that you
will employ for different questions and
different answers that you are pursuing
from these data types
so you can also decide on
different data science skillsets that
you want to start developing so that you
can apply to various comics data type in
general so for those who would want to
go through skill set development
fields or specialization we have a
multiple
coursework that explains or that
introduces you to python environment and
our environment and different data
science applications and machine
learning which includes machine learning
and deep learning methods so all of
these methods can be generally applied
to various data types that one can
obtain from several analysis methods
that that are designed specifically for
different comics data types
so uh
what one example of how these forces are
designed uh
let's let's take a look at designing a
bioinformatics research project courses
so these courses are designed to take
you deeper into those specific
respective topics in a step-by-step
process that are outlined into separate
lessons so for example this is a course
which we suggest to all the participants
so that they can uh
understand the necessary steps involved
in how to design a bioinformatics
project so more on this a little later
so also throughout these courseworks we
have several practical assignments along
the course work and example projects
that takes data from publicly available
resources and the data that are used in
popular research
articles and we will design as separate
analysis pipelines or separate analysis
methods that is going to answer a
research question that is
not
straight
that is not related to what was the
focus of the research paper so we will
take the data and then try to combine
different analysis methods in uh
employing or in using these publicly
available resources to answer the search
question on our own so while you are
going through these example projects you
will get a a good understanding of how
to take a publicly available data and
how to create your own analysis methods
that is going to answer a specific
question or hypothesis that you will
form
from basically understanding
some interaction about the data
as described in the associated paper or
publication so these different exemplar
projects
are
designed to include variety of topics
like in epigenetics human health
agriculture biology immunology precision
medicine etcetera etcetera a lot of
different ones so also microbiome also
so these practical exercises and
these projects will give you necessary
exposure to understand the data driven
discovery of real research
behind these projects and it will also
encourage you
to think critically about how to go
about designing your own projects and
what are the necessary ingredients in
creating a successful bioinformatics
project so
as i mentioned
the basic purpose of the fundamental
purpose of doing these practical
assignments is to
get a deep understanding of data
specific challenges and also to
showcase how various methods are
methods of analysis are applied in real
world situations so when you compare the
results that you obtain
with the one that are focus of the
publication then you can clearly
understand how
the questions are formulated to
get to the publication level from such a
publicly available data or such a vast
quantity of data and that is delta here
so this can be your project at the end
um
and of this analysis also so once you
have acquired all the necessary skills
and you are performing your research in
a
in a good healthy progress and then
you can use these skills to apply them
to various different research problems
that shapes the bioinformatics and
biological research of today so it can
be from physician medicine it can be
from operation health can even be space
in astrobiology so we have various
example projects that
that are categories under different such
different categories so it will give you
uh all the necessary introduction to um
take the data from these specific fields
and then apply your own analysis methods
for the
question that you are interested in
trying to ask from those
so
let's start going through how would you
find it such topics so let's let's take
a
practical approach to and how to
get
how to identify a research topic so um
as we said the major steps that are
important to design a research problem
that we have been discussing so far
is first you have to frame the problem
and then
to frame the problem you have to
understand
what is the latest current trend in that
specific problem so you can by framing
the problem like you can try to
narrow down but i want to work on cancer
or you want to be even more specific i
want to work on let's say head and neck
cancer and then
you can understand the literature or you
can go through the literature review the
literature
the scientific uh
results for the last five years or even
last 10 years on this specific topic so
once you have gone through the
literature you can then identify
that specific gap so
the literature review should tell you
what are the areas that are addressed
more frequently or more in a very
detailed manner and also it should also
give you a hint on what are the areas
that are not covered generally so you
can try to
approach that area or try to take that
specific area and then
collect a raw data that will
or you can actually find publicly
available resources
data that is necessary to answer your
question or your problem or answer the
gap in literature that you have
identified so far so once you have
collected these data then you have to
create a processes or data sequences six
create a pipeline for the analysis
detailed analysis of this data and then
you can yeah you start by exploring the
data to understand the patterns and then
you perform in-depth analysis that you
have designed for the data
once your analysis is complete then you
reinforce from the results and then
perform necessary
biological implications by relating it
to the
characteristics of the sample or to the
nature of the problem that you started
with so
for example in head and neck
cancer that i started with i met up
started with
trying to categorize the tumor tissues
so if i can collect the necessary data
that will help me in categorizing or
classifying the tumor tissues into
multiple categories then i have to find
whether my analysis substantiates this
claim or substantiates of
hypothesis and once my analysis and my
inferences are complete and i can
put together this as a story and
communicate the results to the peers
so let's start how to find a topic or
how to choose a topic so you always
start with topics that you know about or
topics that you care about and
etc for example this could be a personal
reason or this could be a reason that
you are deeply interested in so
you can start by
noting down or actually by
collecting few slides or a few
information uh about the background
about the topic background so uh
then you have to start a preparing or
start spending
a few time in analyzing or researching
the topic so how much has been known so
what has been studied and
among those what is studied what is left
to be studied and what will be
interesting in this uh in this topic
that will be interesting to the audience
and that will be interesting to you also
so you have to do something that you
also care about and then once this is
narrowed down and then you have to find
a data that is going to answer the
question that you can choose from this
uh
from the in this topic for example um
if the topic is very specific or very uh
narrowed down you might not find
sufficiently
studied data or sufficient volume of
data that will answer your question or
if the topic is too
wide or too broad you might find a lot
of data and you will be left with a lot
of choices
to uh
make a good decision so
you you have to find the right balance
that
that will maximize or that will help you
in identifying the data perfect data
that will
answer the query that you have in your
mind so how to do this for example um
so
finding right questions or right sources
are are one of the issues so this is
always a back and forth
process where for example in the
for example in the original research you
take the raw data and then you perform
the analysis and then you compile
different analysis and then you find a
solution or you can also go back you can
take from the publicly available
resources and
collect the date
compiled uh databases and then you
explore for the possible
trends and then from these trends you
can actually design a question whether
the initial
question that i have in mind can be
substantiated by
following some of the trends so we will
get an ex example for this in a while
so uh
for example um
if you
uh
to uh to
narrow down on the topic of research
identification or topic identification
you first
go through the reviews and then you can
categorize those reviews on on
on their
analysis methods and or different
questions that they are answering and
then once you have a thorough meta
analysis done or tarot analysis done on
the reviews that are available or the
publication that i've done for the last
let's say two or five years of the data
then for your topic then you can
identify the unanswered questions and
you can identify the gaps and you can
also identify some of the debates and
controversies which are left unanswered
in the in this topic so this these are
the areas which you need to focus on i
mean on the areas which are
obviously answered by many people you
don't want to reinvent the wheel so we
want to identify those areas which are
not
covered a lot and
which has a lot of potential to improve
the science or which has lot of
potential to fill the gaps in the
science
in that particular research area so that
gap and how to
answer how to
design
specific analysis methods to
answer those caps and answers to some
answer question will define your
hypothesis or question